welcome I'm Jim Levinson the director of
the Jackson Institute for global affairs
welcome to this Jackson town hall
meeting with former UN Secretary General
Kofi Annan mr. Annan is here today to
mark the publication of a five volume
set of his official UN papers a
loose-leaf set of which will reside here
at the Yale library the publication
project is headed by Jeanne Krasnow a
distinguished fellow in our
International Security Studies program
and a lecturer here at the Jackson
Institute Jeanne will come up and say a
few words about the project
thank you Jim it is a great great
pleasure to be here today with all of
you to pay tribute to former UN
Secretary General Kofi Annan the impetus
for this gathering today is not only to
welcome our special guests Kofi Annan
and ambassador John Negroponte II but
also to launch the publication of the
collected papers of secretary-general
Kofi Annan quite a few years ago now I
decided to take on this project of
collecting and publishing his papers
because I understood that if this were
not done the papers would be locked up
in UN archives for 20 years not
available to anyone the five volume set
of books this is just one very heavy so
I couldn't carry all five is available
here at Yale in the Yale archives in
manuscripts library and at the Social
Science Library and in addition unique
to Yale as Jim was saying hard copies of
the original papers where you can see
the handwritten notes and the stamps and
the letterhead are available for
research at the Yale archives library
the ten years that Kofi Annan was
Secretary General were very important
transitional years for the UN after the
end of the Cold War and Kofi Annan if I
may saw his role in a unique way from
the previous six secretaries general he
used his leadership position at the UN
as a moral compass to guide the UN in
addressing the needs of the peoples of
the united nations of the world I felt
we could not allow these important
documents that bear witness to his
leadership to be hidden away and
forgotten I wanted to also mention that
secretary-general Annan has recently
released
his own autobiography and I believe that
his book and the collected papers come
to complement each other in many ways as
he discusses speeches in Kigali Harare
or London or before the General Assembly
the full length of these speeches can be
found in the papers so the papers
include these kinds of public documents
but also I requested for internal notes
to be declassified and released to us
for publication and I must say that
Secretary General Annan was so willing
and is such a transparent person that he
really believed in this project and made
all the declassification process moves
smoothly so I want to thank you and know
I'll hand it back over to Jim thank you
so much
I often hear someone stand up and say
well let me introduce someone who needs
no introduction and then the person goes
on and on to introduce the person who of
course needs no introduction I'm going
to just only slightly repeat that same
mistake mr. Kofi Annan is the seventh
secretary-general of the United Nations
he served two terms from 1997 to 2006
well let the UN Kofi Annan was an
advocate for human rights the rule of
law the Millennium Development Goals and
development in Africa in 2001 Kofi Annan
and the United Nations were jointly
awarded the Nobel Prize for Peace the
citation cited mr. Annan's leadership
for quote bringing new life to the
organization unquote since leaving the
UN mr. Annan has continued to press for
better policies to meet the needs of the
poorest and most vulnerable through his
work with the Kofi Annan Foundation and
other venues he continues to use his
experience to mediate and resolve
conflict most recently serving as the
joint United Nations Arab League special
envoy to Syria I know that because he
was scheduled to be here last year and
was called away to Syria we have what I
think is going to be a fun format today
mr. Annan will be interviewed by
ambassador John Negroponte a ambassador
Negroponte a is the brady johnson
distinguished practitioner in grand
strategy at yale and I'm proud to say a
senior fellow at the Jackson Institute
John teaches grand strategy and a
graduate seminar at the Jackson
Institute he's had a long and
distinguished career in US government
and has held numerous positions
including former US Deputy Secretary of
State the first director of the Office
of National Intelligence he was
ambassador to Honduras Mexico the
Philippines and
and of course is former US ambassador to
the United Nations please join me in
welcoming ambassador Negroponte and
former secretary-general Kofi Anan
so the game was the right flag was it it
was the right flag
well welcome welcome to Yale mr.
secretary-general kofi if I may and one
point that Jim did not mention and I
thank you for the kind introduction of
both of us particularly of the
secretary-general is that my time is
ambassador the United Nations coincide
in this case with the period of sec
secretary-general on on although he
overlapped me at both ends he became
secretary-general in 1997 and stayed
until the end of 2006 I was only there
from 2001 right after 9/11 as a matter
of fact got there about a week later
until the middle of 2004 when I went off
to become the first ambassador in the
post occupation period in Iraq so I
guess I can say without much fear of
contradiction that I was there through a
fairly tumultuous period dealing with
all of what you call in your book the
sort of post 9/11 events Jim has pretty
much covered highlights of your
biography mr. secretary-general but I
would like to mention a couple of things
and maybe emphasize them first is that
you are the first secretary-general who
came from sub-saharan Africa so I think
that was a real first and a an important
point to note another is that you're the
first secretary-general of the United
Nations to have come up through the
ranks so to speak you started your
career at the United Nations in 1962 and
with the exception of a four-year period
when you went back to your home country
to be director of tourism have basically
worked at the United Nations until your
retirement ever since the second point
I'd like to make about your background
is that you were the undersecretary
general for peacekeeping from 1993 to
1996 and this is a bit of a surmise on
my own part but I would guess that that
was probably a career-defining
experience for you both in terms of how
it may have eventually contributed to
your becoming secretary-general of the
entire United Nations but also in terms
of how it might have affected your
attitude towards some of the issues
related to the responsibility to protect
the question of intervening in dire
humanitarian circumstances and so forth
because you were the undersecretary
general for peacekeeping at a very very
difficult at a time so the last point
I'd Michael like to make about your your
tenure was that I think in addition to
highlights prior to 9/11 in Kosovo and
East Timor in some of those situations
of course the post 9/11 period as you
call it in your own book really involved
Iraq Afghanistan the issue of
non-proliferation and then Africa
strengthening peacekeeping operations in
that part of the world to the point that
I think when you left your position as
secretary-general the role of your
office and the role of peacekeeping in
the UN organization went far beyond
anything that had been envisioned by the
original founders of the United Nations
and if memory serves me the Charter
itself doesn't even mention the word
peacekeeping in it so it's kind of
interesting too
in the life of an organization how we
can evolve in a purse in a particular
direction and that very much depends on
the incumbent of the various leadership
positions over the years so I guess to
if I could ask a few questions mr.
secretary-general before inviting the
audience to do so I guess my first
question and a lot of people come to
those of us who've served in public life
and sort of ask a question to the effect
how did you end up where you ended up
how did you get the job you got and what
particularly what were the influences on
your life and what role did your
education play in your reaching where
you eventually reached and were there
important mentors to you along the way
so I guess I would open with that and
obviously if you could answer that and
make any other general comments you'd
like to make to the group to start with
thank you John
it is really wonderful to be here this
evening doing that doing this event with
you since we spent many years together
working on the issues and the challenges
that I discuss in my book interventions
alive in war and peace and let me also
thank Jane and the staff and the
students who work with you on this book
and Yale and City University for taking
on this project but before I get into
John's question let me warn you my young
friends about something that Jim
Levinson said that term we often get up
and say here's someone who doesn't need
introduction it is always wrong let me
share story with you when I step down a
Secretary General my wife and I decided
we were tired and in fact I was telling
your president Levinson that you never
know how tired you are until you stop so
what when I stopped I said we need three
months let's go and hide somewhere I
borrowed a friend's house in Como Italy
said no newspapers no television no
radio for three months after six weeks
hours getting a bit bored as I said to
my wife let's go to the tobacco shop and
get a newspaper we enter the shop and
within minutes a group of men standing
in the corner we're starin at us one of
them broke away and made for us and I
turned to my wife I said oh gosh we have
six weeks to go and we'll blown our
cover how are we going to manage the
village by then the fellow was on top of
me
and he put his hand out and said Morgan
Freeman
may I have an autograph as I said sure I
sign K Freeman he was happy we were
happy kept our anonymity and continued
our holidays so that would teach you to
go saying you don't need introduction
and and John now let me tend to your
question in fact these are questions
that come up often when you meet young
people there are many young people and
people around the world who would tell
you at the age of 10 I knew exactly what
I wanted to be I wanted to be President
of Mexico like a professor's ideal or
something I was not one of those I did
not know at an early age what I wanted
to do but I grew up in Ghana during the
independence struggle so the
independence of Ghana coincided with my
teenage years and I went through this
incredible experience where changes were
happening where everybody wanted
independence we talked of freedom we
talked of Ghana taking charge of his own
destiny another beginning is seem very
remote but it all happened and so I grew
up with the sense that change was
possible even the most radical change
and went through life testing pushing
change wherever I can and even today
when I can I try to push when I'm told
he cannot be done I say let's test it
although sometimes he need to be careful
I recall often at the UN with my staff
they will come to me with initials I'm
the secretary John this is an issue on
which we need to stick our neck out and
now look around and say why do I have a
feeling that when you say let's take our
necks out is my neck you are
volunteering
but even with that you still have to go
out and push a tan taste I also had as
John put in his question I had
individuals who had influences on me
things that didn't seem that important
but when you look back we were in a
boarding school where students we were
role-playing today I'll be the leader of
the Opposition and somebody else would
be leader of the governing party and
would argue with the issues and grew up
really in that political atmosphere
which you could see and I recall once a
teacher come into the classroom putting
a broad white sheet let's say three one
meter by one meter on the board with the
dotted black with a black dot in the
right-hand corner he stood back and said
boys what do you see I say boys because
I was an all-boys school you know it's
not discrimination against against and I
said I said boys what do you see and we
all shouted in unison a black dot and he
said not a single one of you saw the
broad white sheet the one meter by one
meter wide sheet your saw the black dot
don't go through life focusing on the
negative see the positive and then see
the white as well as a dot but it we
know those kinds of things often live
with you my father himself was a strict
disciplinarian who felt character was
the most important that you can earn all
the degrees and make us much money and
be as successful as professional but if
you don't have character you're going
nowhere you lose it all and insisted on
on character and ghanians also happen
that we love proverbs they're over 2,000
proverbs and they use it to teach you to
bring you up for example if John were to
be my boss
and I went home and told my parents I'm
so upset with that boss of mine I'm
going to go and give me a piece of my
mind
when I go in tomorrow morning they will
listen quietly and tell you sedan says
son you don't hit a man on the head when
you've got your fingers between his
teeth and leave it there you you figure
it out
mm either so all these experiences help
so I left Ghana at the end of my teens
went to Minnesota to study at Macalester
College from there I went to Geneva to
the Graduate Institute for graduate work
and that's when I joined a BHO in 1962
assort a relatively young age in my 20s
early twenties I had experienced life on
three continents Africa America in
Europe and also had learned to respect
different cultures and different
environment in fact I recall when I
first got to Macalester for my first
winter from Ghana to Michael at
Minnesota you can imagine I mean having
to load myself with all these clothes
were quite a problem but one item I
refused to eat use was a year muffs I
thought they were inelegant so I said
I'm not going to wear them until one day
I went to get something to eat and
almost lost my ears and the next day I
bought the biggest pair I could find
elegant or not but I also walked away
with another lesson you don't walk into
an environment and believe you know
better than the natives you have to
listen to them and have to watch them
and that also has been a lesson that
carried with me and of course when I
joined the UN I had no idea I would
become secretary-general one day even
when I became head of peacekeeping as
John us indicated for me that was a
limit the undersecretary general was a
limit a career person has ever been no
career person had been a secretary July
was perfectly happy to walk away feeling
average the top of my career and could
go and do something else and then of
course as fateful habit I became the
secretary-general a very difficult
period and as John has indicated we went
through Rwanda Somalia Bosnia Kosovo
with other civil wars around us thank
you for that and with that kind of
biographical background I thought the
next question I would like to put to you
Oh has to do with the UN itself and and
could you perhaps give us your
definition of the United Nations because
we have a lot of debates in this country
about the UN and sometimes they get even
quite heated and after a little while we
realized that we not even agreed on
which part or one UN it is we're we're
talking about so if you could talk to us
a little bit about the yeah diverse
elements of the UN and then also what in
that context with that great diversity
of organizations that are within it what
your priorities were and what you feel
the role of the secretary-general
is or Orton beaten yeah that's a very
interesting question um is sir a very
large organization with many agencies it
is as trimly difficult to explain to the
public what is the UN about 20 25 years
ago no longer than that I went to give a
lecture at Columbia University and the
professor Hanlon is some of you may have
known him was Oscar Shasta Oscar asked
me to send him a brief note as to what
I'm going to speak about and I sent him
a note saying I will speak on the topic
the UN is us when I got there and you
opened the seminar he said my friend
Kofi has given us a very intriguing
topic he wants to talk about and this
topic is the UN is us hurt you as US but
you know it's extremely difficult
because even if you take the UN in New
York alone
you have to EWTN's the UN that is made
up of member states who give us a
mandates who take decisions in the
General Assembly and the Security
Council and the UN that is a circuit
area that takes us marching orders from
the member states and implements it
sometimes effectively sometimes not
effectively but when things go wrong the
tendency to simplify just say the UN we
never get the message across that the UN
is a Member States and the UN can be as
strong as the member states wanted to be
and by dismissing it as if you and his
de un is them we give the government's
an alibi instead of saying the
government must do this or the you if
you take Syria for a while it was the UN
being blamed until I resigned and said
the problem is in the council
and then it shifted but until then twas
the Secretary's not the end boiler but
apart from that you have all the agents
at the World Health Organization the
Food and Agricultural organization they
tell International Telecommunication
WIPO intellectual property they all part
of the UN and it create if you look at
it critically if it wasn't these
international agreements even the
question of communication frequencies
which are regulated by them on the
question of maritime where the UN plays
a role when you look at issues of
intellectual property and the way we
deal with on health standards our life
would be impossible without the role the
UN and it's agencies play we tend to
focus only on the conflicts peacekeeping
or humanitarian crisis but there are
lots of other activities that the UN
undertakes that if it were not to do we
would find our lives very difficult to
manage as an international community but
just to add a little bit to that
question then you yourself though in
your role as Secretary General how did
you yeah I mean no I think what you said
is true but I wonder how it is true the
priorities of the secretary-general
yeah no but I see what will rephrase
that question your priorities no but
you're right that the Secretary General
has room for maneuver the
secretary-general has room for manoeuvre
I don't know if I should say this or / -
this way sometimes the diversity of
membership and the divisions among the
members on certain key issues gives the
secretary-general incredible room for
manoeuvre and room for initiative and
John you may remember even when you were
there there were issues where the
council could not agree on and I a
Secretary General could go out and make
a statement I said this is the position
of the secretary-general and it has
happened that the member states have
come together say we agree with the
secretary generous book position you
sometimes have room to show leadership
and I used to explain to my staff the
member states can give us the mandates
which are sometimes very unclear not
precise but it is up to us to give it
functional interpretation and in
defining the functions or how you
interpret it practically there is a lot
that the secretary-general can do you
can also go wrong and the member states
will not forgive you they were come on
you like a ton of bricks and there were
initiatives that I took and I was able
to sell it to the Member States I mean
there were some times we set up
commissions professors idea chaired one
a financing for development for me and
then you put the report to the members
days and you roll it into action and
therefore and I also decided that we
should focus much more on the individual
we tended as organizational we saw the
UN as organization of states sovereign
states
that were there to protect their
interest but if you look at the
structure of the organization the time
the organization was set up even if you
go back to the treaty was was Westphalia
where borders were discussed the whole
idea of borders instructions were to
protect individuals to ensure we don't
have Wars indefinitely and so I felt we
should focus on individuals on the
peoples in whose name the ideals and the
principles of the UN were set up and
that we were there and the to protect
these ideas and principles but these
principles belong to the people and our
own charter started with we the people's
and that was one of the reasons I
decided we should open up the UN to
civil society private sector foundations
universities and that we could all work
together but there was also another
advantage the UN couldn't do most of the
tasks it was assigned alone and when I
went through the questions of what
should the UN do why should the UN do
alone
what should the UN do with others and
why should you and leave all this to do
it became patently clear that we needed
all hands on deck from civil society
private sector and everything and in
fact by bringing everybody together in
partnership and pooling our efforts the
UN in a way was expanding his capacity
because if we had gone to governments
and say we need a five billion dollars
more to do that we wouldn't get it but
but were rich not and working with all
this we were able to expand our capacity
and get things done perhaps you had
talked to us a little bit about your
experience with peacekeeping both as
undersecretary general and as
secretary-general I think as I said
earlier and I'm not sure that this was
really envisage t' to the extent that it
has occurred
since the adoption of the UN Charter and
today I believe there's something on the
order of 95,000 sk peacekeepers around
the world and close to 20 i think 18
peacekeeping missions and not many
people stay aware yeah of that fact and
one of the points I've always like to
make to Americans is that that we really
get our money's worth from the United
Nations with respect to these missions
in terms of the assessments that we pay
in it it helps avoid having to send
American forces and instead of those
forces and so that sometimes I believe
our peacekeeping the peacekeeping
efforts of the United Nations are under
appreciated no John you were right when
you said the peacekeeping is not even
mentioned by the Charter it was
something which was introduced by one of
my predecessor DAG hammarskjöld
who felt we needed a mechanism of that
kind to be able to monitor peace
agreement signed between states and
between organized armies and so for a
long time we had often unarmed
peacekeepers we have had them in in on
the Pakistan Indian border since the 40s
we've had we've had them in the Middle
East when Bernadotte
went in to try to settle the
israeli-palestinian conflict so they
were very few we had about several
hundred peacekeepers and of course this
was also during the time of the Cold War
then 1989 the collapse of the Soviet
Union there was a certainly four-e-and
expectation in the UN and the council
that now that the world is not divided
the UN can finally do what it was set up
to do and my predecessor commissioned a
report on peacekeeping and also
recommended that we should not honestok
to interstate Wars but we should look at
civil wars which were much more
prevalent and that's where most of the
killings were taking place
so the council agreed and we shifted
into civil war situations without
thinking through the implications that
decision required that the troops will
be facing greater risks they should have
gone in with much more resources and
they should have been better equipped
and be prepared to fight and do a war
where UN peacekeepers were only allowed
to use force in in self-defense but not
to take on effective military action to
try and change the dynamics on the
ground
this latter explosion of peacekeeping in
fact the biggest one we had was a
humanitarian one thanks to President
George Bush senior who decided to send
in US troops to ensure the Somalis were
not starving we managed to get in food
food way in their warehouses but they
were hooligans and brutal elements who
were not aligned the food to leave the
warehouse to get to the people so the
u.s. formed a Coalition of the Willing
and sent in thousands of troops to move
the food to the people until that the
Blackhawk was shot down and US troops
withdrew this happened at a time when
Rwanda was beginning to fall apart and
people in a way I said Rwanda became the
victim of Somalia came under the shadow
because one where we were drawing from
Somalia people were moving our way from
risks and then Rwanda happened and
nobody wanted to take another risk again
and then of course from at the same time
we had Yugoslavia and then Kosovo
so the peacekeeping really exploded and
then you can go on to Sara Leone Liberia
everywhere and today as John has
indicated we have a 96 thousand plus in
the field
that also creates problems run because
you need to backstop these trips you
need to supply them you need to make
sure they are well looked after and it
is not easy if any national government
had 96 thousand troops deployed around
the world they'll probably have doubled
that number back stopping them at home
we have very few people at UN
headquarters back stopping them but you
also have problems sometimes the
governments will allow the UN to deploy
the troops but the UN doesn't have
command we only have operational command
the real command stays with the
government and we've had situations
where governments have instructed their
peacekeepers on the ground not to move
on power to take certain action and this
can be extremely dangerous because it
can put all this at risk and so the UN
Force commander on the ground often has
to not only negotiate with the local
people but also within his own troops
and battalions and sometimes has to come
to the secretary-general to call the
president said do you mind if your
troops move from here to there which is
really not the most effective way to run
an operation but Joan is right is much
more cost-effective on the whole the
cost to the international community for
a peacekeeper is thousand dollars per
month per soldier and very few countries
in particularly the Western countries
can get that sort of a deal with your
own troops anyway this is where we are
but let me conclude by saying that since
we don't have a standing army we often
have to approach governments for the
troops sometimes we get them and
sometimes we don't
and in fact someone was said once say
that the way we run the peacekeeping
operation just like telling Mayor
Bloomberg in
hatton that mayor we know there's fire
sometimes in the city and you need a
firehouse but we'll build you one when
the fire breaks that's the way we run
the operations there's so many different
issues to cover mr. secretary-general
one that I'd like to raise is the
question of un reform correct that the
question or the criticism is often made
that the UN Security Council I'm talking
about the Security Council in particular
knows it very well he was a member and
he sat there I was one of the permanent
five what the advantages of a permanent
five delegate has but nonetheless the
worlds are quite a different place than
it was in 1945 and there are a number of
important rising and emerging powers and
economies and countries that don't have
a permanent representative rent
representation you proffered a couple of
different plans I think during your
tenure for Security Council reform and
thought was put forward of expanding
from 15 permanent members to something
in the 20s 24 26 but then every time
this discussion is got launched the
countries couldn't agree on on who would
be the participant so I'm just wondering
what your what your view is today on the
prospects for you and reform and the
Security Council particularly and
secondly what's your vision for the
United Nations generally and the role
that it's likely to play going forward
yeah are you optimistic no let me start
with the first one first question I
think reform is absolutely essential I
mean the the the council and this
composition is based on the geopolitical
realities
of 1945 the world has changed the world
has evolved the world has moved on in
the UN must and this is why I pushed
very hard to try and get the forms of
the Security Council yes there were
resistance from some p5 members but that
they were not the only ones there to
blame because of but let me step back
and say when you look at the world today
and you look at the five permanent
members and you compare the imagined
countries you look at the fact that
India what about if if a fifth of the
world's population is not represented on
the council Japan second contributor is
not on the council the whole of Latin
America doesn't have a thing I'm talking
about permanent members the whole of
Latin America doesn't have a single
permanent seat Africa with 54 countries
doesn't have a single permanent seat yes
there is rotation and you have other say
commits when we look at the council in a
way the US Russia China and these are
all big boys you cannot tell me that if
during the rotational scheme Africa has
Togo and Gambia they are equal weight or
they bring a certain weight I think if
we are if we need to reform it and allow
these regions to have feminine Seas and
decide who represents them on a
permanent basis when I say it's not only
the permanent members of course if you
were to decide to take away the veto
they will have to agree they agree it's
done in such a way that you cannot take
away the video without the agreement but
and I didn't even push for the removal
of the veto I felt we should add
additional permanent members but what
was a problem on the other side Pakistan
will tell you India over our dead
Africa we talked of eventually to
permanence ease for Africa there were
three African countries pushing for this
Nigeria South Africa in Egypt Egypt
immediately said Oh years to cs4 Africa
one for Africa north of the Sahara and
one for Africa south of the Sahara
Nigeria and South Africa cried foul said
Africa is Africa less compete may the
best candidates a wind so that you get
into the confusion that Latin America I
had a visit by a former president Menem
of Argentina we had a very nice
conversation and then at the end of
sentences secretary-general since our
goodness trimly well in our region we
are getting on well with Chile with
Brazil with Mexico and others and it's
never been better
now tell me mr. secretary-general why do
you want to give us something to fight
over the Security Council feminine
business and assembly sir mr. president
I thought it's important and I suspect
if Brazil were to hear this they will
consider it an unfriendly Act but we
left it then so everywhere you turn
there was a bit of a problem and yet the
world has changed and we need to reform
if we do not reform we are going to
really not get a complete cooperation
that we are going to need from these big
imagined countries so my advice is we
have to find a way to reform the council
those who have the privileges today
should decide not only in the council
Security Council but in IMF in the bank
how much influence they are prepared to
give up to make participation for other
countries meaningful so that we get a
real cooperation rather than destructive
competition it's not easy for people to
give up what they were they want but
I've learned through my life that there
are two things that people find it
extremely difficult
to give up once a habit subsidies and
privileges but we often talk of the
subsidies because it's a privilege
talking about what the poor have and
they want to adjust but the privileges
they often don't discuss but it's
extremely difficult to take it away and
we see it every day in politics here and
in elsewhere so that is the challenge we
have been in in the council but the
council has to be reformed what one
thing I could add on them is a
historical note which was because there
was no veto in the League of Nations I
think that that was problematic and
that's the thing the veto was considered
an essential element of the Charter at
least to secure ratification by the
United States possibly by other powers
as well the other I'll say this
mischievously and then I will turn it
over to Professor Levinson to solicit
questions from from the audience but I
used to kid my French and UK colleagues
on the Security Council saying look you
Europeans you talk about how the world
has changed since 1945 but Europe is
totally over represented on the council
and part of the reason is that Britain
and France each have permanent seas why
don't you give that those two seats up
and let's have a European Union C for
example and you walked out where I live
and obviously that's a non-starter as
well so I think it just raises the point
you make you get push back and then of
course the Reformers said yeah you know
when I started the UN reform within six
weeks I don't know who managed it but
they managed to get an article in The
New York Times that I have not reformed
the UN in six weeks and that day I was
having the monthly lunch with the
Security Council so I started my
comments to the council by apologizing
for my failure to reform the UN in six
weeks and Sergey Lavrov who is today the
Russia's
foreign minister put his hand up and
said mr. secretary-general what are you
complaining about
you've had more time than God had to
create the world and I said to him and
he was the only communist in the room
and the only one coaching God sir sir so
I said to him mr. ambassador you're
right but God had a unique advantage he
worked alone thank you so very very much
we're gonna take some questions from
Yale college students who are members of
the Yale international relations
Association so if you guys could line up
and I think the way we're going to do
this is you could each ask your question
we'll take all the questions and then
turn it back over to Secretary General
thank you
in your experience a secretary gentlemen
during your tenure and epithets
do you think that foreign aid from
organizations like the Global Fund this
prevented sustainable development and
causing Africa to become overly
thank you shorted to the point
good
and these national bodies are able to
prosecute corporate involvement in
illicit extraction of resources
I know that I'm resigning to the special
envoy to Syria among other things
puts into the ongoing deep-rooted
problems of our lack of consensus
touchdown given that I'm wondering if we
could speak to whether you do the UN
today is in fact effective be empowered
to prevent another Rwanda and if not
what obstacles so remain in power in
relation to Syria
would you think ours of the major
challenges and opportunities
in African chatter Aleutians and what do
you think of the potential new
directions of the Development Office
religion what in your view or the
strengths and we can
to the international response to
situation in Bali and how do you
envision the long-term impacts of Mali
affecting security and counterterrorism
and development
one last question No thank you very much
share for those questions and and the
question of the development assistance
offering no country can be bought with
development assistance
one can use it is it better
yeah a boss weapon good boy
technical assistance in Hanukkah and
that's how we use you know the question
was coronated Development Assistance and
I began by saying no country can develop
on the basis of assistance alone you can
use assistance build institutions start
in their capacity and most countries
would want to either free themselves out
of poverty rather than
and there are some countries that have a
situations on foreign assistance even if
the regional development and trade in
structure properties and the afternoon
that systems because
it helps but it's not that solution it
has to be
and the country's live in
abilities
but human rights violations yes I came
up with a concept of
where I asked corporations to sign on to
nine principles covering the areas of
human rights
call a bus terminus the environment
anything
we are the tenth principle the fight
against corruption and the question of
the human rights and violations
companies themselves have become much
more aware and civil society is not very
active in the city I don't know how many
of you follow the very instant case
recently in the Delta region where for
years where for years there has been
that close where for years there has
been you couldn't hear me
that is very eloquent statement now you
can hear me now our saying that I don't
know how many of you follow the recent
case between Shell Oil Company and the
Delta region in Nigeria where they sued
shell for violating their rights for
polluting their land polluting their
water and the court in the hague agreed
that shell was partially responsible and
that this is a very interest in
development because i said somebody who
comes from the south when i watch the
accidents or the pollution that goes on
and I watched BP in Mex in Mexico that
response could not have come for a
third-world country who doesn't have the
power and the pressure of the us
together company to perform and this is
where it becomes important that their
rights are protected and sometimes we
take steps to ensure that they get what
is due to them and and besides these
accidents environmental accidents affect
all of us and so whether they pollute in
us where us has a influence on the path
to get them to clean up and perform we
need to find a way of making sure some
of these things are dealt with elsewhere
on Syria is very tragic is tragic in the
sense that a two year so on we are
nowhere near a solution and I'm not sure
this Security Council is going to come
together anytime soon discussions are
going on I think we need leadership from
the US and Russia I managed to bring all
the five permanent members of foreign
ministers Hillary
Clinton Sergey Lavrov Chinese were all
there in Geneva where we agreed that the
solution is political settlement the
solution is politically Yemi I can't
believe I'm not in Africa I can't
believe it
no I was saying you think I should good
is it better it was one of your
professors who pushed me here directed
me here no I was going to say that Syria
is very tragic and I think is going to
get worse you raise a question if this
Security Council can take action I think
we need the Security Council to come
together make a common cause and put
sustained pressure on the region and the
parties to resolve the issue that is the
only way we are going to see as the
country itself is so hopelessly divided
with tens of militia organizations with
a government that is determined also to
hold on with the region that is
hopelessly divided along sectarian lines
and an international community that
cannot come together in the Security
Council and we need to start with the
Security Council it would be easier to
pressure them to come together and they
did on the 30th of June last year agree
to a political settlement a political
settlement that would ensure that there
is a transitional government with full
executive authority the traditional
arrangements that would ensure all the
minorities that their interests will be
looked after ensure that governmental
structures are in place security forces
are given effective leadership so that
the state doesn't collapse because
chaotic collapse could even be more or
dangerous but the council has still not
been able to come together and as some
of you know one of the reasons I stepped
down was when after the Geneva
communique of 30th June last year
I had expected them to go to New York
and build on that but they went to New
York and the divisions he merged again
you know and that's when I said I lost
my team on the road to Damascus and the
going there alone without that support
there was very little one can one can do
but I think we need to find a way out in
the council any she should begin with
the US and the Russian Federation
Lakhdar Brahimi who replaced me is
trying to work very hard and is in touch
with these two capitals very closely and
I hope you'll get the support he needs
for us to be able to do that because
this is not a type of crisis where one
side wins and the other side accepts and
enjoys him it will lead to revenge
killings it will lead to ethnic
cleansing of the other and it will get
much much worse than it is today and the
only way to resolve it is to offer a
road map or political settlement
indicating what each side gets out of
this but we are not we are not there yet
and I'm really worried about where we
are heading in in Syria the the
challenges of Africa Africa has
challenges of leadership but governance
is improving we have a and better
economic environment in fact the IMF
indicates that in the next decade six
out of the ten fastest-growing economies
will be in Africa we also have an
excitement and something that happened
in Latin America and Asia where bright
young educated young people are going
back again back home to make
contributions they're going to the
private sector some are setting up their
own companies or the scien in the public
service which has to be improved and so
the next generation of Africans are
determined to make us a difference and I
think time for generational change has
come and I'm looking forward to the next
10 to 20 years the kind of dynamic
Africa we are going to have a seat now
quite a few young Africans here smiling
and cheering and I agree this Yauch is
your world now you have to go back home
and make a difference but of course as I
said we also need to make sure we deal
with the conflicts if Africa can become
stable and we can avoid the Democratic
Republic of Congo what we have in there
we can avoid what is happening in Mali
and house a bit more about Molly we will
really be moving forward but let me also
assure you that there has been
improvements even on the civil war side
Liberia and Sierra Leone are at peace
today Angola Mozambique they are all
moving on but we are still stuck with
DRC and today we have a major problem in
mana but I think all Africans realize
that we need to walk away or resolve
these conflicts and focus on economic
and social issues that is what the
people are interested in focus on
economic issues not just oil and
extractive industry we have incredible
potential in agriculture 60% of the
world's arable land which is not
exploited is in Africa today so not only
can we help
has become small business women and take
care of their families India and and
play a role in society we can also
become an important part of the global
food security and nutrition system and I
think there's lots of interest in this
in African governments and other
investors are working with the
government's on this so I'm quite
hopeful on the agricultural front on
Mali he says it's a difficult situation
Mali in a way became a collateral damage
of the military action in Libya these
two erics who were part of Gaddafi's
army went back home with heavy weapons
and the Libyan and the Malian army was
no much and they took over the forces in
the north they took over the north and
some of the Malian forces also teamed up
with them on top of that there was a
military coup by a captain so the
political situation is also delicate
there were tensions between the Prime
Minister and the president so all these
issues will have to be resolved and they
are talking of elections in the course
of the year but obviously the climate
has to be right for that kind of a
election I'm hopeful that if the Malians
can get their political act together and
the African forces are deployed they may
be able to maintain the country as one
unit and also ensure that there is a
stability but they've foreign forces
that is a French forces should not
withdraw to you soon
the vacuum they should make sure that
the African forces are fully deployed
and even when they are fully deployed
they may require air support when an run
and if necessary thank you very much
thank you please join me please join me
in thanking ambassador Negroponte and
secretary-general kofi
you